let's speak to some more people via the
david pakman show discord which you can
find at
davidpakman.com
discord we're going to go next to miles
in bay city michigan miles welcome
hello mr pacman can you hear me just
barely if you can speak up it would be
great
okay so
uh does it still come in through a big
question that's a little bit better
so a good question for you this is kind
of
relevant to about employment because
there's
you know there's a lot of places where
it's like oh we can't find workers well
well most of these jobs they only offer
part-time i can't help but want to look
at some of these
managers and stuff and just like and
you're not offering full-time and
benefits like i can't help but
ultimately look at some of these people
it's like instead of looking for say
five part-timers i hear three
full-timers
i can't help but feel like that in the
end it's like it's gonna cost the
business roughly the same but you're
gonna have someone there to run the
business
and all that and it should function as
intended
you know they'll get people to fill
those jobs if they
give you know you know they offer a
full-time job and benefits i mean i just
can't help but feel like that's just
when i see some of that stuff like that
it's just like the answer's right in
front of you and they're not taking it i
generally speaking agree i mean one of
the things about full employment and we
are really close to full employment i
know right wingers will say oh but
people filed for unemployment last month
that always happens but when you have
3.5 unemployment
the jobs report came in at double the
number of new jobs that was expected
we're we are close to full employment in
this country one of the things is
employers are going to have to fight for
employees to some degree particularly in
these minimum wage or close to minimum
wage jobs
um so yeah i think that that is
it
it's just supply and demand to a certain
degree
very interesting
uh anyway that's just that was on my
mind all right thank you so much for the
call i appreciate it yeah this is a good
point and we're it's it's we're
experiencing it
um in some sectors but not in others and
it's because of what we might kind of
colloquially call the quality of the job